well what's
what's your biggest concern like if if
if i'm speaking with you off camera
we're talking i'm saying arthur you know
there's a lot of stuff you're hearing on
the news right now market crash you know
inflation
you know uh regulation you know all this
the taxes
what concerns you the most right now
financially
there are a bunch of things that i mean
obviously these tax things bother me a
great deal patrick
i mean i i think we're in a bad
situation in taxes
i think this deficit spending is crazy i
mean you know when you have uh
when you have uh uh huge transfer
payments
can i go through transfers with you a
little bit slowly and you know when you
transfer
when your transfer income you take from
someone who has a little bit more
and you give to someone who has a little
bit less you're with me on there yeah
that that's what really is
redistribution or transfer payment there
now whenever you take from someone who
has a little bit more
you reduce that person's incentives to
produce
and that person will produce a little
bit less okay
likewise when you give to someone who
has a little bit less
that person finds an alternative source
of income other than working
for receiving income so that person too
will produce a little bit less he can
make money by not working
all right the the theorem here is really
simple
whenever you redistribute income
whatever you do you
always reduce total income always it's
not a debate
the rich people who have the money taken
from them will produce a little less
the poor people who have the money given
to them also will produce a little bit
less and you'll have a reduction
in total income or output to see it
really clearly if you tax people who
work
and you pay people who don't work don't
be surprised if a lot of people
decide not to work all right now the
lemma from this theory
and theorem is delicious uh and and the
lemma is very simply is
uh the more you redistribute the greater
will be the decline
in total income and that should be
self-evident from the theorem itself
so but the limit function of this
theorem i i just delight in
uh because it's so clear and this is
just math it's nothing else it's not
left-wing it's not right-wing it's not
liberal it's not conservative or
republican
it's just plain math the the limit
theorem is
if you were able to redistribute all
income so that everyone came out exactly
the same patrick if everyone came out
exactly the same
there will be no income whatsoever and
let me
hit that intuitively to you uh to get
everyone to come out the same what you
have to do is tax everyone who earns
above the average income
100 of the excess and what you also have
to do is everyone below the average
income
you have to subsidize them up to the
average income
now if you actually did that if you
actually taxed everyone above the
average income 100
and actually subsidize every below the
average income up to the average income
i'll stipulate today counselor
they're there everyone will come out
exactly the same at zero
income that's what bothers me a lot
we've increased government spending
through these
uh through these quote-unquote stimulus
packages incredibly lahar
and it's working very much to the
detriment of this economy in this
country so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]